alors que dans la plupart des secteurs
d'activité les indicateurs sont
encourageants dans le btp les voyants
sont au rouge
nombreux sont les professionnels qui
considèrent que leur gagne pain est en
danger alors ils montent au front
le malaise est palpable les autorités
désignées comme responsables
je leur ai dit un matin 7h30 que je ne
quitterai par la ctn même si l'appui la
gendarmerie la police voire même l'armée
je quitterai pas là c'est elle dont
j'aurais pas vu quelqu'un à cause d'une
commande publique en berne un secteur
privé affectés par la confiance ébranlée
des consommateurs
l'avenir du btp semble bien sombre